if you have drawn this one and even if
you haven't you can still write this
down
this one is vitally important it is
called and you want to write this down
siapinsky's triangle
okay now it's very very interesting
okay it comes up in a place well
actually it comes up in a lot of places
but one of the places you at least
expect it i'm going to show you
okay so here we go
now i've had to make the numbers very
small
so that i can fit a lot of them in okay
but i'll read out some of the numbers
and you can tell me what this is
one one one one two one one three two
this one
this is pascal's triangle now
you're like big d or pascal's triangle
is really easy all you have to do is add
numbers okay well
actually there are some interesting
patterns in here i'll just give you one
example like this there's literally
hundreds okay but i'm just gonna pick
out one
to do with this guy okay um i know you
can't probably see it but you can guess
right
there are lots of odd numbers and lots
of even numbers
okay now i wonder how do you think
they would be distributed through
pascal's triangle will it be kind of
random will they be in straight lines
where are they going to be
and guess what if you highlight all the
even numbers
you get these guys you're like
are you for real yeah i'm for real and
it keeps going
it keeps going you just get these and by
the way this is why it's so important
that you didn't actually construct the
triangles in the middle right
because you would ruin c offensive's
triangle okay you need to these things
they need to be empty because that they
represent these
right now by the way it's not just even
or odd you can actually try it for
different multiples of different numbers
you could try it for the multiples of
three to try for the multiples of four
you will get
different versions of sequences
triangles
okay speed version because i've got like
four minutes
um the other two factors i want to tell
you what their names were so we had this
guy
um the people who struggled with
trisecting i think it was something like
this
something like this and then you had to
trisect these guys
yes
like that and then you can go again like
this
every edge gets a new triangle
on it now
what does this thing look like
it looks kind of like a snowflake of
songkai it's like or a ninja star if you
like
this again if i can finish it has a name
similar to this
it's called the kosh snowflake
final one cost no flake okay right
very last one which you started by doing
a square and then a triangle
and then another pair of squares and
then more similar triangles
and smaller squares and so on
okay this guy because if you have a look
at it now
i'll shade a part of it that will
illustrate this for you if i
shade in this part here uh this square
and this square
and the square i started with
if you have a look at those right uh
this particular part of the diagram the
part that i've called it in
conveniently with four commas is this is
one of the classic proofs
of pythagoras theorem isn't it like you
can cut up these shapes and you can
rearrange the two
small ones to fit into the big one okay
so therefore this thing if you keep
going
it starts to look like the leaves of a
tree it's called
the pythagorean tree okay
and you can keep going you can get
interesting different kinds of shapes
depending on
what kind of triangle you drew in here
okay
now last thing before i ask you to pack
up
are the people who are doing the cost
snowflake i asked you what would happen
if you did it with a square okay so what
would it look like
here's a square rough one if i
trisect and then i
trisect again
and so on you're still getting
um a similar kind of wow this is gonna
take a while
this is the problem with fractals they
take you a long time
to make got it okay there you go and i
could go again couldn't i uh
well it's not kind of like snowflake is
it but it's a similar kind of thing
it's got and i really mean similar this
kind of scale symmetry
within it okay